an annual religious performance in
Germany has come under fire from the
animal rights organization Petter they
are calling for donkeys to be removed
from the show depicting the last days of
Jesus Christ and suggests instead an
actor rides in on an e scooter these
days Jesus would no longer travel by
donkey he would presumably move on an e
scooter or some other electric vehicle
that his kinds animals and the
environment well the demand has been
criticized by performers the actor
playing Jesus says there they are
representing a specific moment in time
and Annie scooter quote doesn't really
fit the event has been held in Bavaria
since the 17th century with few changes
and it's not just those on stage who've
been slamming the suggestions by the
animal rights campaigners Jesus is
supposed to ride in the scooter instead
of a donkey it could not be more idiotic
I was in Jerusalem and there is a ban on
the use of electric vehicles in the old
town I understand the criticism itself
but seriously Jesus on a nice scooter
while everything around is historically
correct Oh better animal welfare is
taking into account law in Germany and
in European countries in many countries
throughout the world animal where as
well taking into account what is not
taking account sufficiently this human
welfare PETA has had as his mission to
divert attention away from human
suffering and to focus attention on less
important issues and PETA has probably
no knowledge of the German laws the law
of the land is very strict and it has
its limits but it also has privileges
and certain privileged organizations can
as long as they follow the strict
procedures that the law provides use
animals in their performances
you